the libs are mocking Trump and they're
mocking Trump over things that they know
nothing about like this guy on SNL Trump
did have a slight stumble this week
while talking about Banks and he
introduced an interesting new term
called debank we're also going to place
strong protections to stop Banks and
Regulators from trying to debank you
they want to debank you and we're going
to
debank I don't know what the hell dbank
means but he might have to take D
ambulance to see the doctor
this guy doesn't know what debank means
because liberals have never had to deal
with
it and because he doesn't read the news
and because the news he does read
doesn't tell him what's actually going
on in politics and because he didn't
even Google it and doesn't even he
didn't even read the Wikipedia page
about de banking this is this is not
Trump sometimes makes up words like
koffe but this is not a word he made up
this is a real phenomenon